superhero films are dominating the box
office let's take a look at the history
of the genre by way of stop-motion paper
animation great news comic book fans
Marvel and DC will release nineteen
superhero movies in the next four years
some critics say that we're reaching a
saturation point as if the modern
superhero era began in 1978 when DC
Comics and Warner Brothers released
Superman at the time it was the most
expensive movie ever made
its success spawned three sequels and
paved the way for Batman a decade later
but while DC was dominating the box
office Marvel struggled to make a dent
Marvel's first foray into film was the
George Lucas produced Howard the Duck a
lemon that costs 37 million dollars but
made back less than half that amount a
string of failures followed that
contributed to Marvel filing for
bankruptcy in 1996 the company sold the
rights to many of their prized
characters for five percent of the box
office licensing fee things were looking
grim comic book fans until Marvel
licensed blade to New Line Cinema's
which became a modest niche then came
the x-men licensed to 20th Century Fox
and finally Spiderman to Columbia
Pictures the success of these franchises
drove Marvel to form its own studio
the Marvel Cinematic Universe is now the
most financially successful franchise in
movie history surpassing James Bond
Harry Potter and Star Wars when Captain
America Civil War recently opened at
number one at the box office
it gave Marvel an unprecedented 13
number-one movies in a row before this
year the highest market share superhero
films had on the film industry on a
whole was 13.7% 2016 is on pace to
shatter that figure of all consumer
dollars spent on movies this year 27.6%
will go to superhero films but not
everyone believes in the longevity of
the superhero film Steven Spielberg said
we were around when the Western died and
there will be a time when the superhero
movie goes the way of the Western there
will come a day when the mythological
stories are supplanted by some other
genre that possibly some young filmmaker
is just thinking about discovering for
all of us and if that doesn't happen
with over 17,000 super-powered
characters in their libraries Marvel and
DC could be making movies at their
current rate for the next three thousand
four hundred years
you